2000 indultos esa es la fórmula que
utilizará el gobierno de guillermo lasso
para combatir la crisis carcelaria en
ecuador que causó más de 100 muertos en
el ultimo amotinamiento en la
penitenciaría del litoral en guayaquil
tramitar de forma inmediata indultos
personas de la tercera edad mujeres
personas con discapacidad y enfermos
terminales para liberar así el
hacinamiento también decidieron
gestionar el proceso de repatriación de
82 extranjeros en el último año la
prisión del litoral ha sido epicentro de
sangrientas riñas entre bandas
vinculadas al narcotráfico el gobierno
dijo que para evitar el paso de armas
que entran a la cárcel incluirá entre
las medidas de seguridad un escáner de
carga tras el decreto del estado de
excepción el gobierno ha desplegado
policías y soldados del ejército para
reforzar la seguridad dentro de las
cárceles el gobierno mantiene
movilizados de manera permanente
diariamente en todos los centros
penitenciarios del ecuador
a 3.600 efectivos de la policía nacional
y de las fuerzas armadas las altas
cifras de hacinamiento en el centro
penitenciario llegan al 62% y ha causado
fuertes críticas en contra del gobierno
mientras aumenta la desesperación de los
familiares que esperan por los cuerpos
de los detenidos que perdieron la vida
en el motín yo como madre quiero saber
si es que el mismo vida o no
me encuentro desesperada hasta el
momento han sido identificadas unas 40
personas de las 118 las familias siguen
esperando por noticias de los reclusos